t
bien vamos a hablar de innovación
educativa y
si yo les pregunto a ustedes qué imagen
tienen de la innovación educativa
piensen un minuto
puede ser algo parecido a esto
yo hace mucho tiempo que trabajo en
diferentes proyectos educativos y
siempre me solía encontrar cuando
hablamos de este tema con dos bandos los
fanáticos tecnológicos y los fanáticos
anti tecnológicos
yo como muchos consideraban que la mejor
educación en la que me había tocado a mí
entonces cuando empezamos con el tema de
las computadoras en las escuelas no
estaba muy de acuerdo
creía que iban primero a hacer todo
mucho más fácil segundo que iban a bajar
el rendimiento académico y tercero que
íbamos a convertir las escuelas en una
sucursal de wikipedia por ejemplo
gracias a cortar y pegar
yo sin darme cuenta estaba mirando esta
imagen
la de una escuela del siglo 19
la pedagogía de la normalización
en qué consiste básicamente en dar al
mismo tiempo y a la misma velocidad la
misma información a un grupo de
estudiantes sentados mirando hacia
adelante hacia un profesor que es el
dueño del conocimiento que se los da
como si fueran unos recipientes vacíos a
los que hay que llenar
una política una pedagogía que fue
producto de una política de estado pero
que a medida que fue pasando el tiempo
se fue agotando tanto que expulsó a los
jóvenes de las escuelas y en nuestro
país subió mucho el abandono escolar
había pasado el tiempo
pensé que obviamente en un mundo
interconectado la escuela no podía estar
aislada
y pensé también que estábamos por
empezar a educar a jóvenes generaciones
de internet con docentes formados en
épocas pre internet entonces dije
hagámonos para ticos tecnológicos
pongamos computadoras en las escuelas va
a cambiar todo
y no sé si la imagen cambio
me parece que no cambió mucho o sea
entregar computadoras a los chicos a las
escuelas no fue la solución porque la
escuela secundaria sigue siendo un lugar
superficial fragmentario enciclopedista
desconectado de la realidad
y lo que nos dice eso es que tenemos 50%
de abandono escolar en la escuela
secundaria
pasado el tiempo en el año 2015 esto ya
estaba dando unas charlas en la
provincia de misiones el ministerio de
educación me propuso diseñar una
plataforma de innovación educativa y ahí
me di cuenta que los dos extremos
estaban equivocados porque los dos
limitaban el vasto mundo de la
innovación educativa apenas sea una
parte a la parte tecnológica
y así descubrí
el secreto de la innovación educativa
que es un sistema es un sistema del que
tenemos que hacer muchas cosas a la vez
a diferente velocidad
capacitación directiva diseño curricular
normativa supervisión
conectividad a dispositivos tecnológicos
formación docente con esa idea entonces
diseñamos
plataforma guacurarí que es el programa
innovación educativa del ministerio en
base a cinco conceptos que son muy
sencillos de entender y de aplicar
el primero es centrado en los
estudiantes la provincia de misiones una
provincia pequeña que muchas la conexión
a por las cataratas del iguazú
y tiene unas particulares de
interesantes el 90 por ciento de sus
fronteras limita con brasil y con
paraguay eso sumado el hecho de que
tiene una gran inmigración europea y
mucha fuerza a los pueblos originarios
le dan una cultura muy diversa y rica y
además es la provincia más joven del
país el 40 por ciento de su población
tiene menos de 18 años tiene 22 años de
promedio de edad fíjense que el lugar
extraordinario para ofrecer a los
jóvenes un diálogo con el futuro
si mejoramos la educación ahora en 15 ó
20 años es probable que tengamos mejores
gobernantes mejores políticos mejores
policías mejores personas
el segundo elemento considera una
política pública educativa hay un
concepto de política pública educativa
que me gusta mucho que es el de ventanas
de oportunidad
jon kingdom que es el que más trabajó
esta idea decía que se abría una ventana
de oportunidad en política pública
cuando confluyan tres corrientes primero
la corriente de los problemas es decir
cuando los problemas eran de tal
importancia que pasaban a estar dentro
de la agenda prioritaria de un gobierno
la segunda era la corriente de los
acontecimientos políticos cuando el
gobierno tomaba decisiones para poder
resolver el problema y la tercera la
corriente de las soluciones que cuando
existían soluciones eficaces y posibles
para ese problema evidentemente con un
gobierno toma una decisión de apostar
por la innovación educativa es una
ventana de oportunidad y creo que
nosotros somos privilegiados para poder
aprovecharla
el tercer concepto es el de metodologías
activas
en el mundo hay un movimiento global de
actualización en educación para pasar
del aprendizaje pasivo al aprendizaje
activo a través de las denominadas
metodologías activas nosotros elegimos
una metodología denominada flipped
classroom o aula inversa
primero porque consideramos que además
de tener muy buenos antecedentes de
mejoras académicas en diferentes niveles
y países del mundo era la que más se
adecuaba a nuestra realidad
sociocultural y también porque se ha
probado que mejora mucho el clima del
aula y las ganas de ir a la escuela de
los chicos pero en qué consiste esta
metodología en qué consiste el aula
inversa
obviamente no solamente en esto vamos a
dar vuelta de esta manera el aula sino
que consiste en invertir
el proceso de enseñanza-aprendizaje de
manera tal de transferir fuera del aula
normalmente en la casa la parte más
fácil que es la instrucción directa la
explicación de un tema y reservar el
tiempo de aula para las actividades de
conocimiento más complejas
con un ejemplo se va a entender mejor
normalmente en una hora de clase 40
minutos un profesor se toma los primeros
cinco minutos para explicar un tema
luego 20 25 minutos para perdón para
explicar el tema y 10 o 15 minutos
finales para dudas consultas o algún
alguna actividad un poco más profunda
para sus estudiantes y después los envía
a su casa con la tarea que normalmente
son actividades más complejas a su caso
donde está solo no tiene obviamente al
docente y a veces ni siquiera tiene
alguien que lo ayude a diferencia de
esto en el aula inversa el estudiante ve
primero
el vídeo con el tema en su casa ese
vídeo lo ve con una pequeña guía de
estudio es como ver un capítulo de los
simpson digamos y cuando va a clase lo
único que hace el docente es primero
chequear que hayan visto el vídeo si
alguien no lo vio lo puede ver en el
aula o en otro lugar del establecimiento
y luego tiene todo el resto de la hora
para trabajar
con sus con sus estudiantes en sus dudas
en algún tipo de actividad más compleja
en proyectos en aprendizaje colaborativo
de esta manera que pasa lo que decimos
nosotros y se produce una mejora
automática del tiempo de aula porque el
docente a sacarse esa actividad que es
más extensa pero poco efectiva tiene más
tiempo para dedicársela a sus
estudiantes que necesitan más atención y
también respeta los tiempos los
diferentes ritmos de aprendizaje y una
interesante consecuencia también es
cuando los docentes graban sus vídeos
porque los graban tienen que revisar su
didáctica porque tienen por el qué
condensar 20-25 minutos en ocho minutos
de un vídeo lo que hace que actual y sta
actualicen y enriquezcan su propuesta
educativa y también algo que le encanta
mucho a los estudiantes es la
posibilidad de poner en pausa alguna vez
al docente que está hablando para
dejarlo de escuchar y volver no escuchar
las veces que sea necesario hasta
atender el tema
el cuarto elemento el uso de la
tecnología
la tecnología en la educación es como
una caja de herramientas
siempre tiene que ser una solución nunca
puede ser un obstáculo no podemos decir
hoy no tuvimos clases porque no andaban
las computadoras es decir tenemos que
usar la tecnología para sacar al docente
de las áreas más repetitivas y menos
efectivas de darle más tiempo con el
alumno porque porque de esta manera
ponemos el mejor recurso que tiene la
educación que es el docente al lado de
quien más lo necesita que es el
estudiante en el momento que más lo
necesita en la escuela
el estudiante siempre va a necesitar al
docente al lado porque el estudiante no
sabe lo que no sabe
de esta manera el docente se transforma
en un guía
en el desarrollo de su pensamiento
crítico y en actividades más desafiantes
entonces lo que hicimos fue diseñar una
plataforma web con inteligencia local
con gente de la provincia con todas las
funcionalidades para hacer aula inversa
pero también con un detalle muy
importante que es la posibilidad de
navegación offline
qué es una gran solución para los
problemas de conectividad que tienen
muchas familias y obviamente muchos
estudiantes también como todos tenemos
uno de estos el bolsillo
la plataforma se puede seguir desde los
celulares se puede trabajar también
desde ahí
y por último el quinto elemento de este
sistema es el tema de la formación
docente
cuando uno proyecta un sistema de
innovación educativa
quienes lo de vélez ahora adelante son
los docentes que están frente al aula si
no están convencidos si no están arriba
del proyecto si no lo entienden si no lo
comprenden si no saben el por qué y los
beneficios ese proyecto va a fracasar
entonces nosotros lo que hicimos
sabiendo que cuando es una propuesta de
arriba hacia abajo puede verse como algo
ajeno o como algo no deseado por muchos
docentes hicimos un trabajo de
convencimiento fuimos a las escuelas
recorrimos nos reunimos primero con los
directivos y después con todos los
docentes dos tres cuatro veces hasta que
conseguimos cuatro o cinco docentes
pioneros le decimos nosotros en cada
escuela que son los que están
anclando nuestro proyecto y los que
están llevando adelante son los primeros
adoptantes o shirley adopters de nuestro
programa y hasta ahora ha sido bastante
exitoso el trabajo en formación
estamos trabajando en 25 escuelas 300
docentes y 5.000 estudiantes este año
con la progresión de tener el año de
si en escuelas 1600 docentes y 20.000
estudiantes
entonces esto es
un proyecto estamos trabajándolo y no
puedo decir que vamos a tener grandes
resultados en este momento porque
estamos en proceso lo que sigue en el
camino que fuimos haciendo lo que a
nosotros nos dio muchas enseñanzas a mí
particularmente puede extraer de todo lo
que hicimos cinco enseñanzas que me
gustaría compartir con ustedes
la primera es de las ventanas de
oportunidad
a todos nos define lo que hacemos pero
también lo que dejamos de hacer cuando
tenemos la oportunidad
si fuimos capaces de
aprender y de aceptar una oportunidad
también debemos estar a la altura de
trabajar para que las oportunidades se
multiplican hay una frase que me gusta
repetir que es que el talento está
repartido de manera uniforme pero las
oportunidades no
la segunda más tecnología no es mejor
educación la tecnología no viene a
reemplazar al docente ni tampoco tenemos
que ir a un mundo sin escuelas
porque si no estaríamos renunciando a la
parte más importante de la educación que
es ese contacto cara a cara la relación
humana
tenemos que ser inteligentes para usar
la tecnología para humanizar la
educación
tercero la innovación ocurre en
cualquier parte fíjese que le estoy
contando una experiencia de la provincia
de misiones
1 34% de la coparticipación nacional
y lo estamos haciendo entonces no es
cuestión de acá no podemos no se puede
no hay plata no hay recursos no hay
decisión si lo hacemos de millones cómo
lo podemos hacer acá cuánto universidad
en tu escuela en tu provincia tenemos
que entonces tomar la decisión de poder
hacer porque es posible iniciar ese
cambio
cuarto el tiempo en educación no son
días son años
la urgencia que todos sentimos por cómo
está la educación es para empezar los
cambios pero esa urgencia no nos tiene
que exigir
resultados inmediatos porque de esa
manera estaríamos iniciando el camino en
las frustraciones al fracaso todo
proyecto tiene una planificación un
desarrollo y unos resultados
y por último qué es lo que más
me gusta a mí es el cambio personal
nada va a cambiar en la educación si
antes no cambiamos nosotros que somos
los que queremos cambiarlas
y por cambiar me refiero a involucrarnos
con ideas poderosas inspiradoras
creativas
y también a intervenir personalmente en
políticas de impacto real
en la educación
tenemos que ser agentes y protagonistas
de ese cambio si no estaríamos sentados
siempre diciendo esto no va más
esto no funciona esperando que otro haga
lo que nosotros podemos hacer
mientras tanto mientras tanto el 50% de
nuestros jóvenes se van de la escuela
secundaria
abandonan y salen a la vida sin las más
elementales herramientas y habilidades
para desarrollarse como personas y como
ciudadanos y eso está pasando ahora acá
en esta provincia en el país
debemos entonces iniciar
este cambio para pelear contra el tiempo
y la desesperanza
y de volver a la escuela esa fortaleza
que tenía es el brillo que tenía para
que vuelva a ser el lugar donde los
jóvenes quieran estar
y en el camino
mientras vamos cambiando vamos haciendo
y es un cambio les aseguro que se siente
aquí es un cambio que inspira que
contagia vamos ayudando y creo que todos
vamos mejorando como personas porque al
final si mejora la educación mejora todo
muchas gracias
[Música]